il lui a fallu quelques mois de
démarches mais aujourd'hui à rolle h et
peut enfin rouler avec l'acadie lac
qu'il convoitait notre location était à
terme donc simplement rajouté six mois
j'ai dû moi qui on va trouver un moment
donné sinon ça va aller à l'automne donc
je me considère très chanceux d'avoir
élevé quelques jours parce que trouver
une voiture neuve a rarement été aussi
difficile c'est vrai chez le
concessionnaire jihem de la rue papineau
à voir aussi peu d'auto disponibles ne
serait ce que pour les montrer aux
clients
ce soir certains que c'est quelque chose
qu'on a qu'on n'a jamais vus c'est vrai
aussi chez toyota sur la rue rachel cp
que j'ai jamais vu pour définitivement
ils sont pulsées pull en avant des
véhicules que sa dette est
définitivement partout en amérique du
nord les inventaires sont au plus bas
les consommateurs ont économisé et se
ruent vers les voitures sauf que la
production est encore au ralenti
on a fait la demande qui est très très
forte et d'offres qui est faible parce
que ni constructeur la difficulté à
s'approvisionner à certaines pièces
c'est surtout le manque de semi
conducteurs qui pose problème
ces petites puces électroniques
fabriqués en asie dont la demande a
explosé pendant la pandémie car elle
entre aussi dans la fabrication de
nombreuses appareils domestiques vent ce
qui arrive c'est que les véhicules sont
bâtis sont mis de côté à l'usiné
attendent de recevoir des micros tchèque
pour être capable
des explosifs selon le modèle et la
marque il faut donc attendre de quelques
semaines à plus d'une année pour
recevoir son véhicule les camionnettes
les vo us et les voitures hybrides ou
électriques sont les plus attendus le
fait que ça touche autant de segments de
modèle dans l'industrie sauf erreur
alors le meilleur conseil qu'on peut
donner aux consommateurs c'est peut-être
d'attentes
si c'est pas pressant de renouveler son
véhicule de nombreux acheteurs se
tournent vers les véhicules usagés faute
d'en avoir un oeuf il y a donc là aussi
une grande pénurie et madické a pas
beaucoup d'heures sur les marchés il
faut attendre sur les sites de revente
comme chez les concessionnaires les
vendeurs ont le gros bout du bâton et
les prix sont élevés à celles ci ont
dorénavant 120 160 véhicules d'occasion
on en a 65 environ 70 le client voit sur
le marché regarde commission véhicules
vos jetons essaie de le condamner change
ou de les acheter faut être compétitif
parce que si on n'est pas compétitif
qu'il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui va
l'acheter via des membres qui nous
appellent qui nous disent des choses
comme j'ai un fort 950 que j'annonçais
21 mille dollars et on m'a appelé la
journée même pour me dire vous le vendez
pas c'est cher moi je vous offre 20
mille dollars pour votre véhicule et
cette année et ceux des appels comme ça
on en reçoit quotidiennement le ca appel
à la prudence
il ya des bonnes affaires à faire de ce
côté là et les consommateurs qu'un qui
veulent se départir de leurs véhicules
doivent s'assurer que celui qui veulent
acheter est bel et bien disponible pour
pas se retrouver assis entre deux
chaises
selon les analystes il y aura une
pénurie de véhicules au moins jusqu'à la
fin de l'année
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio-canada
mourir